The next location is Langfossen Falls, which translates to "long waterfall."
This waterfall is less of an activity and more of just an attraction.
I mean, you're driving down the highway,...
...out of nowhere, you hear this noise,...
...this rumbling noise, then you see the mist.
You turn the corner and you see the largest,...
...most menacing waterfall on Earth.
This waterfall is over 2,000 feet high.
The World Waterfall Database declared this waterfall...
...to be one of the best in the world.
That's got to tell you something.
I drove past this waterfall on my way to Voss,...
...where I did some whitewater river kayaking.
Langfossen is the perfect place if you're on a long road trip in Norway...
...to just pull over to the side of the road, have some food,...
...enjoy the beauty and just kind of take it in because it is quite the sight.